today I'm going to have I'm going to
talk about this topic that I'm calling
representation technologies and so what
do I mean by that and so I'm going to
start with my problem statement in one
slide and my problem statement is that
my clicker doesn't work my problem
statement in one slide so this is a
chart that developed by Mark Graham in
this group at Oxford internet Institute
and this shows the distribution of
user-generated content that's indexed by
Google and you can just see that it's
dominated by a few countries most
notably the United States a little bit
in Western Europe but you can see large
countries with huge populations like
China and India still relatively
underrepresented on the Internet and
this isn't even talking about
disparities within countries which are
in some cases even more stark where
we're seeing that the Internet as a
phenomenon is still only reaching a
small percentage of the population in
particular in terms of authoring content
and creating content and representing
one's own perspective and so this leads
me to the topic of my talk
representational technologies and so if
you think about information technology
is a tool it's fundamentally about
representing and communicating human
knowledge but the problem is is the
Internet as a place for doing that
still only represents a very small
fraction of human knowledge in terms of
the sources of that knowledge the kinds
of that knowledge and the forms of
knowledge that are represented there and
so the hypothesis from my talk or the
thesis statement from my talk is that we
must design for diversity and diversity
not only in the kinds of users that we
design for but also the forms of
knowledge that they hold something
there's a short outline for my talk you
know first time I talk about a project
called a laws day which thinks about new
user interfaces for having allowing
underrepresented groups to author
content for the internet or internet
like systems then they might talk about
local ground which rethinks processes of
data collection data analysis and
visualization to support goals of
learning and access so people can
understand what day it is and what kind
of roles that can play in society and in
other important venues and finally I'm
going to talk about in the context of
local ground whether these kinds of new
forms of knowledge and new processes of
handling data and knowledge
can actually lead to more equitable
political representation and I'm going
to leave that as a kind of open question
because I really don't know the answer
to that question quite yet so first I'm
gonna start with a wise day and so a
wise day is trying to address a very new
kind of user group for the internet and
the user group and I'm going to talk
about is a typical small farmer in India
who's working as a particular primarily
in the agriculture space and these kinds
of users are you know so far not really
engaging in Internet not really
definitely not creating content for the
Internet in in appreciable numbers and
so this is a system that that we've
tried to build to address some of these
limitation it's called Allah as day
Allah as day means give voice in Hindi
and the reason for that will become
apparent in a couple of slides so I'm
going to build on for this talk this
kind of concept of orality and so a
typical small farmer in India if you
think about how they create knowledge
and how they access knowledge and how
they share it amongst their communities
it's typically through word of mouth
they either hear something interesting
and they act upon it or they tell their
friends about something and they act on
it right and so this is process of
word-of-mouth where things are exchanged
through conversation and primarily
through oral conversation with one's
peers and and other associates and so
what's wrong you know working in in in
the early 80s wrote a book called
orality and literacy where he proposes
that these kinds of oral communities not
only communicate primarily using these
kinds of means but they also have
fundamentally different ways of
organizing and managing and dealing with
information and knowledge so these means
are different in several ways so one way
that they're different is that the
knowledge bases these kinds of
communities tend to create our aggregate
of the aggregate knowledge as opposed to
being reductionist where they try to
create very well-defined hierarchies of
knowledge and what that means you know
one example of this kind of knowledge
basis is mythology so if we think about
mythology there are many many different
stories some of them are redundant they
make the same point in different ways
some of them may even be conflicting
they make different points you know
religious mythology is being a great
example of this and so these
knowledgeable tend to be a great event
poster reductionist to a basic set of
principles
ideas second there since you was
situational they're directly tied to
issues and concerns and circumstances
that are important within specific
context right they're not meant to be
discussing abstract principles or ideas
they're very much tied to real
day-to-day lived concerns and finally
their dialectic you know they're these
kinds of knowledge bases are built up
through conversation and discussion as
opposed to created from scratch and so
we have lots of these kinds of knowledge
bases on the Internet you know using
that as an example Twitter is another
example so lots of different examples of
knowledge bases that have these kinds of
properties of orality that have been
discussed here so if you thought we had
is that can we build a version of this
system of an oil or allottee inspired
knowledge base for small farmers in
India and so I did this work with neil
patel whom i'm sure a lot of you know or
at least know of use a graduate student
here in the ACI group also worked with
scott clemmer and and this is primarily
his work but i'm going to be talking
about we also work very close with a
not-for-profit organization to design
the system called development support
center it's a NGO located in Ahmedabad
in Gujarat in India and they have a lot
of expertise and knowledge and working
with small farmers in that region so the
system we built was very simple it was
basically a voice based interactive
voice response system which provided you
three top-level options one to be able
to ask a question or post a message to
to be able to listen to and respond to
questions of other people and three just
to hear news about about your community
Motty acceptable best news vomit Ebola
Desna - amber vomit Ebola mighty radio
so the kinds of questions that the
system got you know are questions that
have to do with basic concerns of
farmers you know so for example if they
want to grow cotton where it shouldn't
house they grow it Martie kabak me Judy
to our side over and some of the
questions could be more technical
falcomon antigens real couldn't another
ability our model personality there will
always be another honor during Japanese
isomcarol year and attracted Koreans
Unitarian reflector so once the
questions recorded they came to a
moderator a moderator was in charge of
actually managing each of these
questions the moderator used to
interface not unlike the kinds of
interfaces you use for managing your
communique synchronous communications
like an email inbox for example your the
difference being that is that because
this was voice content the moderator
also had to add some metadata to make
this content easier to refer to in the
future and so they added information
about the caller where they're from and
they also categorized the question that
according to what topic it was
considering and in what crop it was
related to so based on this information
the question was assigned to one of a
pool of potential experts these experts
were lead farmers that were known to DSC
or were known to be a had expertise in
specific topics or in specific regions
and so when an expert was assigned the
message they got a call at their house
or on their phone which allowed them to
answer that listen to the to the
question potentially answered if they
had an answer and then finally if they
didn't have an answer or if they thought
it'd be a better resource for her for
that question they could forward it to
another farmer in their network who
might have that kind of expertise and so
in this way the system grows this
network of potential respondents in a
kind of viral way finally if once an
answer was provided that answer would be
sent again asynchronously to the farmer
and they would be able to listen to it
and also to potentially respond to it if
they needed some clarifying information
or if they wanted to provide some
context for the for the response or if
they wanted to just to say thank you
yeah
let's see the end this autumn the system
and they fall back right and then
finally could Brook Bacchus if they want
to destroy this for later reference they
could just bookmark it and so they can
review it later by calling a system
finally the last component is that if
there was an answer or message that was
relevant to a large network of potential
farmers like let's say there's a new
pest in the region or the weather is
gonna change or something like that then
they could be broadcast to all farmers
that grew a particular crop or lived in
a particular region and how does the
system know this well it knew this by
based on what questions each person had
asked before and so they could send this
notification now to everyone who'd asked
a question for example about cotton and
so in this way this this question and
answer well you know we build up these
essentially the equivalent of message
threads but using voice you know this
kind of asynchronous back-and-forth
between farmers between experts and
including peers as well so you know
we've run the system continuously in
Gujarat in India for for over four years
now and so that long experience has
allowed us to run a number of
experiments using this deployment
essentially as a testbed and so the
first experiment we ran was just to kind
of show the feasibility of this kind of
approach and so we ran a pilot
evaluation with about 65 farmers with
all of these functions and features and
that evaluation showed the system was
first and foremost useful the farmers
were using it quite frequently they were
getting a lot of value up from it at
least anecdotally and also we were able
to observe and document some of the same
kinds of social dynamics that we see on
the internet you know this idea of there
being a power distribution of users and
also one one very popular practice was
just looking on the message boards just
listening to the questions and answers
that were going on as a form of
entertainment and so we had examples
where farmers where they had to go out
into the field at night and water the
fields they would just call up the
system put their headphones in and just
listen listen listen two kinds of things
people were discussing so that was a
very promising start you know we also
shared that farmers in general and
contrary to what a lot of technologists
thought prefer just simple touch-tone
input you know if they had to choose
between one and ten options or they'd
rather just press the number
and having to guess what word to say to
make the speech recognition behave in
the correct way and so that was one
thing we documented both experimentally
and through continued usage of the
system and then more recently you know
we've had a couple of additional results
which out which I'll talk more about in
the next few slides and so one
experiment we ran was to compare how
influential information was that came
from peers as opposed to experts and so
one of the properties of modulo that we
are a large day that we've had since the
beginning is the ability for peers other
farmers to answer one another's
questions and so what we wanted to
assess was that with that with their
real value in that kind of approach you
know where farmers valuing information
from peers as much as information that
was coming from experts and so we ran a
controlled experiment where we recorded
seven agricultural tips you know in
information that would be useful for
farmers and in their practice on
different topics and we recorded all
excuse me all of this all of these tips
from two different sources and both
agricultural scientists and also from
pure farmers and so the structure of the
tip was as such at first in the first
line the source introduced himself they
said either
hi I'm an agricultural scientist from
such-and-such location or hi I'm a
farmer from such-and-such location then
they recorded the tip and the tip
content was may remain constant across
both sources and finally we provided a
phone number where the farmer could call
back for additional information about
that tip and that was the behavioral
measure because to call back they'd
actually have to use their own air time
and their own hard-earned money to make
that phone call and so this was this was
a this was what we were looking for
so each farmer received a mix of sources
including both farmers and experts and
we saw it happen and surprisingly we we
found more follow-ups more people call
back on their own dime when the source
was appear as opposed to when they were
an expert and now this was a really
interesting finding because in all of
our interviews and surveys farmers
consistently said that they preferred
information from experts and so this was
a very very surprising finding and to be
honest we still don't understand why why
this was the result that we obtained
we have some possible explanations there
should be a slide on those explanations
but some possible explanations include
that you know that that there's a bias
here you know these farmers have had
prior experience with the vada at Louis
they were just used to receiving pure
content and so they had become
accustomed to to obtaining that kind of
information and so they're more likely
to act upon it another possible
explanation is that there's a solidarity
effect that farmer hasn't wanted to
express their solidarity with other
farmers and so they really were calling
back because they they appreciated
getting knowledge from from their peers
another possible explanation is that
there's a novelty effect you know when
this kind of expert knowledge is
distributed typically it comes from
experts people from universities people
who work for a think tank and so just
getting that content from a farmer was
potentially a new thing for them and so
they responded because of that a final
explanation and you know personally what
I think is the most plausible although
we don't have a lot of evidence for it
is that there's a perceived social
desirability of getting information from
experts you know that because we're
experts you know we're scientists we're
coming from the United States from these
prestigious universities when we talk to
farmers obviously they told us yes we'd
like to get information from experts
because that's perceived to be the right
answer and and when they were able to do
what they wanted and when they were they
thought that their choices wouldn't be
visible to us they actually did what
they preferred which was getting
information from from peers and and and
and so we have to have a little bit of
evidence for that because when we tried
another measure which was we had farmers
wait on hold - so after the call that
they were told that you can you can hold
on and you'll be able to talk to an
expert or to this farmer and we measured
how long they waited on hold you know we
just made them wait for minutes and
minutes you know a little bit mean but
you know that's what we did and they in
fact we had longer to talk to an expert
than they would have waited to talk to
appear and so that says again that maybe
if they perceive that their decision
would be visible they were making quote
unquote the right choice as opposed to
what they preferred but again we don't
have evidence for ruling out any of
these potential hypotheses yeah with
these communities so with a farmer that
got haul know the farmer that was
or the expert or so on no they didn't
have any fun all right but they didn't
know who the individual bus control for
that so this was one finding we found
and it's worth some follow-on work to
see what's really going on here so
another thing that we've been doing in
collaboration with some economists from
Harvard is that we're conducting a
randomized control trial assessing the
impact of this system on farmer
productivity decision making adoption
etc etc and so we're running a
randomized control trial with 1,200
farmers where some fraction is actually
being provided access to this service
and some fraction is not and so we were
finding so far is that of the treated
farmers those are provided access to
this service a significant fraction are
using the system almost 60% add about
60% a majority of that of those farmers
have already asked the question in terms
of participating in the system and of
that 40% or 32% of ask the question 16%
of answer to question answered another
farmers question midterm survey that's
done the final survey is not done in
that final survey is going to actually
look into those word-of-mouth kinds of
questions where people using the system
would be the names of farmers friends we
know who their friends are we know the
people who they talk to
and so we can go back and look at
whether those farmers perform better
whether treated farmers friends perform
better than treated farmers non-friend
right so that's a great question but
something we don't have data for yet and
so they make a missed call to the system
and they immediately get a call which is
on our dime right but it'd be great to
see willingness to pay also which we're
not assessing in this particular study
so we're not finding so far so one thing
is that you know even on this larger
scale with the caveat that Scott
mentioned that farmers still aren't
paying too
dissipate we are still seeing some of
the same rich social dynamics that we
saw initially and are much smaller and
more limited initial experiments oh yeah
those those those those findings do
happen durability also we're seeing that
there's a significant impact on former
decision-making and so early on through
the system
farmers were recommended to use a
pesticide that was more effective for
the pests that typically plague bt
cotton which is a genetically modified
form of cotton and this is against you
know usually farmers just use a
traditional pesticide which is not
effective against those same pests and
we find that the farmers that have been
treated to service are significantly
more likely to use that more effective
which is also a more environmentally and
personally health friendly kind of
pesticide are more likely to use the
alternative that that's been
disseminated through the system we also
find that for the farmers that have been
treated through the system through
interviews and through surveys they that
they almost always cite this service now
as their primary source of agricultural
information as opposed to input
suppliers you know the ones that are
selling them the pesticides and and the
fertilizers who-who are obviously biased
and what they might recommend in terms
of what they have on stock and what's
most profitable to them and also farmers
from their village who may not be as
knowledgeable as the sources are that
are that are represented on this system
so a lot of evidence for for the impact
of the system at least at the midway
point we still aren't to the point of
actually assessing the impact on
productivity and income which we will be
doing at a later phase so there are some
limitations in the study some things
that we're finding that there are still
problems that we need to address so
first of all not everyone has used a
service you know even though it's free
40 percent haven't used it why we don't
know the people that are using it we're
finding are more educated than the ones
that aren't right that's also a
surprising finding especially since
we've done so much work on making the
system accessible so all kinds of groups
and so there is still some kind of
digital divide here it may not be a UI
issue anymore it may be it may be
released other issues that are more
social or more related to personal
psychology we just don't know but it's
still a digital divide even in terms of
using this kind of service
that said you know the decision-making
is not affected by education we're
finding farmers that haven't gotten the
information they're they're choosing to
take up the advice regardless of
education but we are finding that
they're not understanding why they're
doing what they're doing and so we in
the messaging to farmers we tell them
not only which pesticide to use but why
they should be using it and they use the
right pesticide but they don't know why
still and that's also more true for for
less educated than more educated farmers
and so there are some limitations but
but I think these are interesting
questions for further inquiry I'm
getting a lot of positive feedback about
the system you know we regularly get
congratulatory phone messages that just
say how valuable the information is that
they're receiving through the system you
know in this case not only do we get
some thanks but immediately the farmer
asks a question which shows again the
value of the information that the
service is providing and some things we
can't describe it all so this is just
you know a traditional folk song and the
interesting thing is that this guy would
record six renditions of this song right
and so just as weird as the Internet
right you know so so that that shows you
know weird people are using this service
and doing weird things on it which is
one thing I love about it you know and
so I hope to continue to see this kind
of phenomenon so some of you probably
know you know after after a number of
years of running the service we decided
to launch a startup Neil and I'm myself
that essentially provided this is a
hosted service you know initially we
just did this because no one else is
going to do it we needed someone who's
going to host the computer host the line
take care the technology and if no one
else was going to do it we had to do it
and so through that process we found
that agriculture was not the only use
case we're finding other organizations
that are coming to us in the area of
Education and turn in the area area of
Health in the area of labor transparency
that also need this kind of voice hosted
voice service and so we're now working
with a number of these groups to
essentially provide them this platform
across the entire country of India in
fact one of them in fact was a Stanford
group with Stanford Group is using the
service to essentially monitor the
distribution of subsidies to two to two
villagers in Bihar and so continuing
long tradition of Stanford using
Berkeley software so revisiting this
outline I talked about a large data
which talks about this idea of making
user interfaces more accessible to
underrepresented groups on the next part
gonna talk about is local ground and so
local ground is really about making the
process of data management and data
processing more accessible and in this
case not to farmers in India but to
youth in the East Bay and so how can we
make the process of data management data
processing data analysis visualization
more accessible to the communities that
we work with there were primarily high
school youth and finally the last
question that local grant is asking
which I'll revisit towards the end of
the talk is that can these kinds of new
forms and processes of knowledge
representation actually have an impact
on political representation can we make
a difference in how the world works and
I'm not sure I really have an answer to
that question yet but it's something
that I do want to pose um so before I
start I want to visit this idea of medow
representation so you know a lot a is
very successful in terms of collecting
this kind of unstructured knowledge from
communities you know all knowledge
knowledge that's situated in specific
context but if we want to aggregate this
knowledge if you want to make some kind
of an aggregate decision if we want to
analyze this data this nod has to be
processed it has to be and processed
often means converting that knowledge
into some kind of categorical structured
or qua or quantifiable form and so how
does that process work and so this is
related to an idea called meta
representation proposed by decison and
others that that says that actually this
is a very nuanced and-and-and-and-and
and an important literacy to have you
know this ability to to convert
knowledge between different
representations and to be able to choose
the best representation for any given
task or situation it's actually a key
literacy is it
it shows deep learning of the underlying
concepts that that knowledge embodies
and so can we build this this kind of
literacy around meta representation
around empirical phenomenon data it's
really the question that we're asking
here and so we thought we start with a
representation that's in some sense very
very familiar a map you know a map
essentially indexes knowledge by place
it ties knowledge to specific locations
geographically and so this project local
ground is essentially a tool that allows
youth and other communities to collect
visualize analyze and present spatial
data this is joint work with my former
master student and current PhD student
Sarah Van Wert her dog was not involved
although did provide moral support and
also a number of youth and community
groups across the East Bay that we've
been working with including the Lawrence
Hall Science Center for citizen schools
at UC Berkeley I seed and an Oakland
Unified School District although they're
on this line and so you know here's the
general process we're trying to support
you in this process of scientific
inquiry you know based on empirical data
and so this process starts by posing
research questions asking research
questions right you know and then the
important part of it is actually
choosing the right question how do you
decide what's the right question to ask
it right and so once you've done that
you have to actually construct measures
that help you answer that question
collect data that that that that that
that that that is relevant for those
measures and structure that data and
finally analyze that data to either
refine your hypotheses verify them or to
make new kinds of inferences and so this
is the process of inquiry that are
trying to support and for us the first
step is observation just taking stock of
your environment seeing what's going on
what's there what's relevant what are
the questions worth asking and so I'm
going to start this by talking about one
use case which is planning a park and
this was in Richmond which is a city
just north of Berkeley which has
numerous issues which I won't go into
here but this particular project was
about involving youth in the planning of
this park as part of a larger process of
civic engagement with the community and
so the first step for us was just asking
youth what was going in that Park now
well how is that space being you
what was around that part what were the
relevant things in the environment or in
the community that people who were
planning this park should be aware of
right and so they did this in relatively
low-tech ways the first and most
effective low-tech way was just drawing
on a paper map and so the first thing
that local ground allows you to do is to
print out a paper map and just draw on
it to take notes about what's going on
in that space and so here you see some
examples you know here I guess is that
this is a map of Kennedy High School I
guess here's where the troublemakers
hang out you know this is where they
play kickball swimming pool it's really
loud over here but lots of kinds of
observations about that space and and
how it was being used and so this brings
up kind of the first tension or decision
in this kind of process that we don't
start with measurement we start with
observation we just start with taking
stock and this leads to kind of
open-ended kinds of of findings that
can't be neatly tied down to any
specific kind of indicator or data
collection instrument right and so we
found lots of things that we may not
have expected to find when we started
this project you know so for example we
found that the Nystrom Village Community
Center in parentheses this not very
welcoming it's just not a not a good
place you know and then someone else
said it looks like a crack house in fact
you know and so you know you know these
are the kinds of things we were finding
you know this this area has low fencing
you know it's a robbery type area you
know would you have created an indicator
for a robbery type area no probably not
you know and so these are the kinds of
findings that are just surfaced by this
kind of open-ended data collection
strategy that allows you to just draw
take notes write in the margins you know
do things that would not be possible
with a structured form so once you've
collected this data on paper you can
take a picture of it or you can scan it
and using some very simple computer
vision we're able to extract all the
annotations and put them on a Google map
and this is actually a very powerful
process you know once the students saw
that what they drew could be digitized
in this way and hosted on the Internet
all of a sudden their data was on Google
and that's how they referred to it our
data is on Google
and that gave their data their voice a
credibility that it didn't have before
right and it was a very interesting
thing and it continues to me we know
people don't call the system local
ground they call putting it their data
on Google you know that's literally what
they refer to it as right and so just
that process of digitization confers so
much legitimacy on community data so
they were able to collect all of these
kinds of hand-drawn annotations and they
were also able to add other kinds of
data in this case a picture so here's a
picture of a methadone clinic which
happens to be across the street from the
park and happens to be across the street
from where the planners had decided to
put the slide and the swings right and
so of the youth were like immediately
like you can't put the slide in the
swings there there at the methadone
clinic there's all these guys passed out
right in the street in front of there
and so it just shows that again all
these different kinds of data can have a
dramatic impact on what's actually done
at the level of decision-making once the
data has been digitized we can kind of
interpret and analyze it right and so
here you see a lot of drawings of
cupcakes what do you guys think that
those cupcakes mean
but those cupcakes meant and so we have
to go out back and ask students what
those cupcakes meant and so when we went
back and did that someone's like Oh
cupcakes men that means making it out
you know cupcaking cupcaking is making
out and so they referred to making out
as cupcaking right and so this shows us
that while the initial data was
ambiguous you know it's completely
ambiguous to us what that data meant it
became precise through this social
process of interpreting the data and so
what this illustrates is that precision
is not inherent in the in the data
itself precision can also often arise as
a process social process of interpreting
data and placing it in context right and
so this shows that you know precision is
not something we can always expect to be
there at the starting point so here you
see cupcaking spot and she's actually
created a legend if we had looked
closely we'd have seen that there's a
legend here where she's put hearts here
and all the cupcaking spots are labeled
with a heart right and so there's in
fact some evidence you know we could
have feared us out if we tried hard
enough so this next step once you have a
sense of what the important questions
are what the right indicators are
cupcake whatever it might be then you
actually go and collect data that can
help you answer the questions you're
interested in right and so for this I'm
gonna talk about another use case and
another project that we did in Oakland
in East Oakland with Castleman high
school and Oakland Unified School
District where we were looking at food
access and in particular looking at
grocery stores grocery stores that are
there in Oakland and in East Oakland in
particular so this data set we
downloaded from the state of California
Department of corporations you know all
these purple dots refer to grocery
stores in Oakland so when we show this
map to youth at Castle montt they're
like hell no they are not that many
grocery stores where we live there's
just no way there are that many grocery
stores right and so what they did is
they design this data collection
instrument that allowed them to go and
visit each of those stores point out on
the map where it was and then collect
some structured data about each of those
locations and so they noted down the
name of the store a qualitative rating
about how good the food was there
categorize the store and all
so some open-ended notes right so once
they collected this data again using
relatively simple computer vision
techniques we were able to extract all
the annotations extract all of their
notes and provide an interface for them
to digitize this data on their own as a
group in the class right and so they
took each of these observations and they
just digitized them one by one
right and you know amazingly this is
data entry it's boring it's lame but the
students loved it it was super fun
because they were doing it together
it was allowing them to interact with
technology and where they hadn't done
before they were actually creating and
managing data as they digitized a row it
showed up in the map and they again the
data was on Google right so data they
had just written down on paper was all
of a sudden on Google visualize just
like the Department of corporations data
right and so this shows another tension
between automation and participation now
as a computer scientist I might have
said well we'll just collect that data
using tablets or I'll use OCR to
digitize all that data that would
clearly be more efficient but that
wouldn't give students the kind of
visceral feeling and understanding of
what it meant to participate in that
process of creating that data with their
own hands through their own labor right
giving them a sense of the provenance of
that data where did it come from how did
how was it created how did it become
digital how did it come to arrive in a
form that could manipulate that data
right and so this shows like that
there's a trade-off here between how
much we automated versus how much we
give people an opportunity to
participate in that process oh yeah
Jesus said so when you want to automate
and when you want to not because I think
all of us have had experiences where
moving more people in has exactly the
buying experience we talked about on the
other hand we could get rid we could
throw out the window and then probably
not with one head so if you promote
designers
how do you decide when to automate and
when to euthanize okay that's a great
question so so I've another general rule
without a rule for our particular goal
and our goal is learning you know our
goal was giving students the process of
learning what data is where does data
come from how do the data become data
how does one use data and if one's goal
is learning about data then I don't
think automation is the right answer
I don't know if there's a general rule
but at least in this instance
participation trumped automation and you
know it'd be an interesting empirical
question to ask actually to compare
these different interfaces where one in
one situation it was done automatically
and in another situation it was done
manually and whether or not our goal of
learning was actually fulfilled right
and I mean that'd be an interesting
question to ask again empirically right
you know it where's your time best spent
and so all I can say now is my intuition
right and so my intuition is that this
was the most fun the students had during
that whole summer was actually
digitizing their data so it's strictly
on a fun metric right they had a great
time and I think fun is an important
part of learning right and so
anecdotally I can say this is an
important way to use our time so one day
digitize that data off the geo
referencing it by dragging the marker to
where that observation actually occurred
again on the map where that came from
yeah in the process of categorization
some groups might have used slightly
different terms to refer to the same
thing and they were able to converge on
a standard set of categories through
that process right they were able to
discuss you know some people visited the
same place and so they're able to
discuss their findings socially as a
group while they were digitizing that
data so that's a great benefit that I
didn't mention is actually that process
of digitization gave opportunities for
interpretation and reflection and
social sense making also yeah great
point now you see you know these were
supposedly all the grocery stores in
Oakland and in East Oakland and we find
out that in fact no all of them were not
grocery stores right some of them or
convenience stores some of them were
liquor stores some of them were
specialty stores and some of them we
still don't know what they are but
they're clearly not grocery stores right
and so again this showed that you can
have a voice they can have a voice on
saying is this data actually true do we
believe this data what our perspective
on this same phenomenon right in the
sense that we we just put this out there
and said you could use this if you
wanted and wasn't something that was
part of course do you get the sense of
what it would take to get them over that
hump to start I really want my breath so
what is it that was it once they bought
in there was like some cost fallacy and
they're like yeah actually this is
worthwhile well I mean this was like
you're more fun more engaging more
fulfilling than what they typically do
in the classroom right and so that was a
little bar to get over would they rather
do this than playing video games or
listening to music or watching TV that's
probably a lot less likely there's a way
to get citizens engagements and
scientific method in a sense school
program school districts with teachers
right this is educational software it's
not fun software so I was really
intrigued by your early remarks
tremendous assets that are a better
representation and seems like harvests
were like the scaffolding for the
students you actually made a lot of
representational decisions on their
behalf so I hope about cutting time I
wanna hear more about how the students
get involved in choosing the referee
that all the more bursary stores and you
can also see you know how they are
perceived in terms of quality right and
so again getting back to this issue of
representation this is not the only up
resistant representation that the
students used to understand this
phenomenon right they also just took
pictures of the stores made slideshows
conducted audio interviews right and so
this shows you know in terms of
representation how we can combine
qualitative and quantitative data to
give us deeper and more nuanced
understandings of this kind of
phenomenon right and so just you know
not through live voice through the
students voice we'll look at some
pictures and interviews that they
conducted themselves how was it when you
went inside
it was dirty when I went inside and I
would never eat anything in there hell
no because it's they don't sell any
groceries and it's just a bunch of junk
food in there just came out of like a
supermarket it was called cos Ollie's
and it was I liked it I feel like
everything was organized and it was nice
and I saw like the workers fixing
everything that were like out of place I
still have a hall and stuff but it's not
like
so again you know qualitative day that
reinforces two quantitative findings and
this creates so much more richness in
the observations and how we understand
those observations and just seeing dots
on a map so the next step is to
visualize data and you know I know
there's a lot of experts in this in the
room so I won't overstep my bounds but
you know we're going to talk about you
know different ways that this kind of
data can be visualized right and so for
this we might talk about a third project
which is around visualizing air quality
around the BART system and so for this
project we were working with the
Lawrence Hall of Science
eBay z-- program it's a similar program
of scientific inquiry for for youth and
so youth took these particulate matter
sensors and they rode a whole Bart
system basically and so here's the kind
of data they collected across Bart you
know these air quality readings range
from green to red and you can see that
there are some situations where there's
just not good air quality right and so
why you know why why is that why is that
the case and so another important thing
is to be able to understand data in
context right and so we were able to
overlay these quantitative readings on
Street View to understand where that
data came from what is the source of
that data what's going on there what's
the situation what's in the environment
how is it being used right in addition
to the pictures and the audio and all of
that right and so this shows the
Coliseum and the air quality walking
down the street that the students
collected right and so this shows that
we have to be able to understand data in
context not devoid of context right with
context where does it come from what is
the environmental context of where where
that data how we interpret this data how
we make sense of it how do we use it to
create new hypotheses refine our old
ones right and so that's exactly what
what the students are going to tell you
comes to chasing them we thought with us
because other cars on the freeway
I guess outdoor park stations so we
think on the crossover freeway is
sending them via stuck in traffic
they're moving and so all of these
recordings and visualizations here they
actually come from presentations that
the students made to the community and
to the BART public relations people
right and so the students were actively
involved in choosing the representations
that they would use to make specific
empirical points and you can see this
process of interpretation that really
leverages all of these kinds of
different representations that students
were creating and and aggregating and
and it shows also how that process of
interpretation can lead to both the
verification of hypotheses you know in
the case of Embarcadero they had read a
paper that underground train stations
have less air quality and they were able
to collect data both qualitative and
quantitative to verify that hypotheses
and also refine hypotheses right so
initially they thought that the
Pittsburgh station because it was on the
highway would have poor air quality
because of all the cars that were
passing there right but they actually
collect data they went there they saw
what was going
and they found that was not the case so
finally you know they've been through
this process of of scientific inquiry
through data and the last step is to
present the results and hopefully
present the results in a way that they
can have an impact right and here I
revisit the last question which is can
these new forms and processes of
knowledge representation actually have
an impact on politics and so for this we
revisit Richmond and so Richmond as
you'll remember students were involved
in really in planning a local park and
what they decided what they'd really
like to see in that Park is a graffiti
wall they were really psyched about it
right and so this shows a 3d model that
they constructed and again took a
picture of and overlaid on the map to
show how they would like that park to
evolve and so you can see a graffiti
wall you can see a running track you can
see some paths a garden and so they took
all of these different visualizations
and they made their case at a town-hall
meeting with lots of community groups
were presenting their ideas about how
that Park should be designed and used a
busy street so here like a growing
community where I say
it gives you a sense of the complexity
of our lives
to consideration that's not an actor the
factory a guy that works for the
Richmond town office right is wearing
the suit on purpose he's official right
so he understands where the youth are
coming from you understands how they're
collecting this data and how they're
using it to make their point right but
after this whole process after this we
thought the students did a great job
presenting their idea their perspective
advocating for them at the end town
managers like no graffiti wall there is
not gonna be a graffiti wall in this
park right because that's just not the
way he thought that the city of Richmond
should be represented and how the park
should be laid out and so that was
tremendously disappointing to us for the
students for everyone involved with that
process and this just shows that data is
only a part of the political process
right it's only part of it you know
politics Trump's all at a certain level
and so we're still grappling with this
you know we're still grappling with with
this whole you know process and how
students can have an impact in their
communities through science through data
while dealing with the political
realities that exist at that point you
have them go out and get statistics on
where other places had data and graffiti
walls and sort of data in that larger
world since I think I don't think in
this case we need that I think those
have been great thing to do right and I
think I think they can have leverage
students can have leverage this kind of
process if they collect the right kind
of data if they refer to it in the right
way and that's at least the hope right
and and so our strategy right now is to
prompt you know one prong is that we
want students to have a voice we want
youth to have a voice we want them to be
able to advocate for the things they
want but if that doesn't work out we
want them to learn something to that
process we want them to learn skills
having to do with data having to do an
analysis having to do with advocacy and
presentation that they can leverage for
the next battle right and so this is
this is the plot the two-pronged
approach that we have and you can see
you know and the students believe the
same thing they realize the realities
you know I'm going to talk show a video
in the next slide about about the air
quality situation and how students
thought what they were doing what role
look at play in making things different
you cannot make a change if you don't
know there's a problem
so therefore you have to recognize it
and allow others to acknowledge this of
it work that process out coming up with
the solution can be really better than
killing so that's our whole point of
doing this research because we know that
with everything hit each other
coefficient by something said the BART
station
he'd have to tell up here if they
listened to what you were saying and hit
the decrease because you know they
change something out of our system but
increase so chose you know students
realize this is an ongoing process right
they have to continually be engaged they
have to continually be advocating for
the things that they are right and data
is just a tool one of the tools that
they have in that process right and it
requires this process of continually
monitoring continually analyzing
continually interpreting and making your
case to the powers that be so one of the
challenges we face is how do we get
continuity you know students are in
school for a limited number of years
right then they graduate and they're out
in the big bad world right how are we
going to create some continuity around
this work in a way that it can really
make a difference I don't have an answer
the final you know I'm going to revisit
all of these kinds of tensions that I
laid out because I think we're asking a
deeper question here we're asking a
deeper question about what data is what
is data where does it come from
how does it become data how is it used
how can it make a difference right and
we're asking these questions at the same
time as the youth arm because I don't
really know the answer either
and I think of local ground is
essentially being a probe to ask these
kinds of questions of what data is what
is it you know what's the difference
between an observation and a measurement
how does precision arise in data how can
we use qualitative and quantitative data
in different ways the questions God
asked when is it right to automate when
is it
right to increase participation right
these are all I think very important
questions about data that we don't have
answers for and we think of the tool
that we've built and the processes that
we're facilitating as ways of at least
giving us more insight into these kinds
of questions we have lots of things
we're interested in doing you know Sarah
is just a first year PhD student so we
have many many more years to work on
these kinds of things and so we're
interested in thinking about how this
kind of tool can improve data literacy
at the K through 12 level we're working
on partnerships with school districts
with teachers with community programs to
answer these kinds of questions that
means assessing impact impact on
learning impacting on civic agency
impact on career we're also interested
in you know how do we combine data into
influential narratives how can we create
narratives that combine again multiple
representations of data to make a point
and how can those narratives be one easy
to author and two convincing these are
the kinds of questions we're interested
in there there's you know we think
there's more applications of this kind
of platform that go beyond youth go
beyond education you know for example
community planning in the developing
world or even in the developed world
contributing data to online repositories
of maps you know that's another area
that I think has some potential for
future work dealing with situations that
are blank spaces on the map you know how
do we populate those you know after a
disaster things are dramatically altered
in terms of infrastructure can we
document some of that and so they'll be
able to facilitate answering some of
those questions which we won't to answer
all of them you know we're going to be
releasing a public beta of this system
this summer or anyone who wants to use
it ken we've already got 50 users using
it for all kinds of weird stuff but just
as a summary of local ground so first
you know why paper you know paper kept
things loose you know it wasn't about
looking at a phone and pressing buttons
you know it was about drawing it was
about remaining present you know having
the attention in the right place right
and other people have made at this point
in the past but we saw it we saw it
firsthand you know a lot of the groups
we were working with we're previously
using PDAs or mobile phones and all they
could talk about is how much trouble
they had with the technology and that
all went away it all went away and it
just became about the process
and then also facilitated this
combination of accessibility in
expressive 'ti everyone could contribute
data and they could contribute whatever
kind of data they wanted drawings notes
cupcakes annotations things in the
margin right other than we found you
know is that both teachers and students
really like this combination of science
and advocacy advocacy for your community
of science meaning it gave the reason to
do science right because it can make
your your place a better place
I mentioned this about how digitization
can increase the credibility of data and
finally I talked a little bit about how
data is just a part of the political
process if I I just revisiting the
outline you know I talked about allot a
which is about rethinking user
interfaces for making content or
authoring more accessible to
underrepresented groups and then I
talked about local ground which to think
about rethinking the data pipeline for
supporting these goals of learning and
access and advocacy and finally you know
this big open question that I still have
is whether these kinds of new forms and
processes of knowledge representation
can actually have an impact on politics
and I think that's a big question and
when I look forward spending the next
decade on thanks very much
well you know I teach a social
entrepreneurship class a lot of the
products that came out of our class are
kind of in the crowdsourcing space and
so if you're interested in that we can
talk about it offline and any questions
yeah one of the challenges is to measure
understand pop goes bananas for the u.s.
program not effective Ernie can we done
that in this project in that assessment
space and I think you look included
combination of performance-based
assessment and also kind of kind of work
that can surface kind of case studies
anecdotal examples of specific kinds of
mechanisms that worked were found to be
yeah that's the next phase we put in
building the system we actually local
ground to make it easier or is this
something about where you're we're
creating something that wasn't ever
before like is this something where
you're trying to actually think
something that they didn't they weren't
aware of and just in front of them I
think so I think an answer your question
we're doing both I think you know I
think we are trying to lower the bar in
terms of being able to author this
content without necessarily having
digital devices or regular access to
digital devices like smartphones like
PDAs like desktop computers a lot of
groups we work with don't have access to
those kinds of devices and so in this
kind of model they can just draw or take
pictures if they have access to a camera
or they get a camera access to a camera
through their school and they can
contribute their data right so in that
sense it's lowering the bar
in another sense that's allowing them to
contribute kinds of data and contribute
to data processes in a way that they
didn't have access to before right and
so for example being able to collect
this rich open-ended qualitative data
around drawings and and that just wasn't
possible before we built the system
right we won't if you see businesses
realeza that objective being on Yelp
because they have no control over what
you might see here the city of Richmond
might say look we have all of these and
you look at Richmond now all of these
structured things about how how crappy
are our infrastructure is or how much we
didn't listen to our citizens that's a
great question we don't have an answer
that yet so all the things that we're
collecting right now it's essentially in
private projects that only the teachers
and students have access to they're not
publishing this data publicly for anyone
to go on the internet and use you know
we want to do that we want to make it
possible for students to be able to
publish this kind of data but one you
know we want to students to be in charge
of that process we want them to feel in
control of it both for learning and also
for empowerment right and so that's
where that work on authoring data
narratives comes into play right we want
not only this data to be in raw form but
for them to actually construct
narratives that bring this data together
to make points that they'd like to make
and they think resonate with their
perspective well the Richmond City be
cool with that no no probably not but
you know people pass that next to the
park right you know I think but just as
Google has the right to decide what
should be on Google versus what should
not be on Google we want youth to have a
voice in deciding what should be on
local ground versus not be on local
ground right everyone's got a choice in
the matter none of this is this neutral
right and so in this case we want the
choice to be with the youth and will
they make different choices than Google
will make yes will they make different
choices than the Richmond City will make
yes and I'm and and they're up for it
man you know if you go and see them
present this stuff they're totally up
for it man they're ready to take anybody
on and we want to give them tools in
that battle yeah yeah
yeah it's purple questions so you had
the slide where you had all the
different questions about data is asking
deeper questions about data well I
thought it was interesting this one is
it's important to know that none of
those are new questions you know
certainly ever since the birth of
statistics and scientific measurement
people asking questions like that and
there's various answers may depend on
context and what I really like about
this project is I think what's more
important than answering those questions
any research sense is finding the right
types of activities like you're doing
here they get people to understand those
the nature of those questions in a deep
manner so in some sense but know the
deep thing is what you accomplished not
really interesting I just wanted to make
that comment I think that's really an
exciting development that comes out of
this new questions either what I see
this as a platform as a probe as a
technological probe branch for giving
people kind of an intuitive sense of
those questions right now those
questions are new but the probe is in
your arms are giving us new light into
those questions and the questions around
the politics angle so one has already
totally shocked when the graffiti wall
tonight is right now I had the city
administrator however yeah putting the
slide person all children across the
street from the methadone clinic was
interesting so I was wondering if there
were other successes even if it was a
smaller form which in some ways is more
directly tied to observational data
right that doesn't interesting any
others you have any thoughts on
certainly the the students response to
the feeling of being heard even if the
action isn't taken which is often a huge
part of participatory planning as well
right yeah and actually don't have good
answer so I think they're good questions
I don't have answers to you know I don't
know where the slide ended up and to you
know I don't know if the youth how they
felt in primary because I mean this is a
loosey-goosey answer but Sarah was a
master student she just wanted to build
the system she didn't want to research
it
I want the researcher I've continued to
want to research it and that's why I've
got her back as a PhD student so we can
answer these questions that you're
raising which are very good ones but we
just haven't answered yet yeah
I wonder if you can see a little more of
what that organization needs presently
and save my students is a bidding
conference is it having the possible
questions is it giving them your answers
and what does it mean for everybody else
right so a couple of things that you
talked about there the BART station and
possibly igniter there and I'm sure this
site gives insights of its earnings so
is the sign of legitimizing knowledge
opening up the opportunity to is a very
confidence to a point where you think
that says little is rather than final
analysis I think for the most part about
an equal playing field you know like
when the data is on Google and their
data can be viewed in the same screen as
data that comes from the Department of
corporations right they feel like both
of that data has the same legitimacy you
know it's it's not like their data is
just folk data it's on paper it's in
their classrooms it's in their
conversations with their peers it's
actually on a platform where it can be
overlaid on data that comes from
official authoritative sources you know
for students right in terms of the
underground stations and stuff and I
think that the process of being able to
contribute designs not necessarily
creating new science but just having the
experience of contributing designs and
some of that is just replicating results
going through the process for yourself
and and having that kind of experience
of creating new knowledge even if it
isn't new for the universe it's new to
you right and so you the second part
your question so so what is putting yes
I love that I don't know the answer
right you know I don't know whether when
I guess you and Akane any kind of
material sense you know I know what it
gets students again anecdotally from
their own sense of participation of
contribution of self-worth right again
anecdotally we have some observations
that say that was meaningful but will it
change the world I don't know I don't
know the answer to that question yet
that's a worry that each dive into Sigma
issues a collective responsibility for
individuals list may be a hypothetical
some student puts a derogatory personal
comment on the house of somebody who's
frustrating this but wait a minute this
is a you know the kind of comment you
don't want to have a thing do the other
students take responsibility for that
and discuss keeping it on and off that
kind of stuff I think those are related
to the next set of questions we want to
ask especially when we talk about
publishing these rules and making them
public right right now they're still
being used internally for sense making
right just for students to decide what's
going on we've never had a discussion
with them of actually publishing that
data of making it accessible to
everybody right and I think when we have
those kinds of discussions is then these
kinds of issues and I don't know how
they'll react to that kind of question
because their tone to begin with is just
very you know they don't want to get
along you know they don't want to get
along with the institutional
powers-that-be that's not their goal
they want to push back they feel a
screwed over and they want to have an
opportunity to raise their voice and so
will that always be hunky-dory and will
it be smooth I don't think so but
politics isn't always that way so when
you talk about this kind of collective
responsibility you know I think there is
a kind of collective feeling within that
community but whether that collective
responsibility is aligned with the kind
of greater Civic sense that we would
like to see or whether the government
would like to see I'm not sure
presenter articulate the arguments or
counter arguments that your data is
addressing so one of the concerns of the
policymakers about this Punk what is it
that they care about what are the what
are the beliefs that need to be covered
getting what you want to be the endpoint
of your narratives over therefore that
provides counter-argument to whatever it
is that means the person you're trying
to persuade isn't yet persuade either
way you're trying to convince them okay
so that's more separate rhetoric kinds
of support our guests yeah I'm wondering
if you've thought anything about that
space or how the sort of data side
what's the world - like side connects to
the what should the world be like side
in terms of persuasion or policy change
much about that question to be honest
you know this is kind of the first
volley as it were you know it's the
first volley in that rhetoric right so
this starts a conversation I don't know
how it supports the continuity of that
conversation I don't know the answer to
that so yeah I mean I think this this
allows students to at least participate
in the beginning of the conversation I
don't know how that whole conversation
plays out and I think a lot of that
conversation probably happens offline
and I don't think it's going to happen
through the tool I think it's gonna
happen in the real world and through
public venues and community meetings etc
etc and what our hope is is not that
this tool embodies that process but it
provides them some tools to support a
particular perspective within that
process that answer your question the
great success or a huge dud so what were
some without a prophecy the winners win
and how do they prepare to the end
result labels may be a big surprise you
got out of it
we're really anticipating and it got to
get kind of a glib answer but you know
but our hypothesis always the same you
know it's like pinky in the brain you
know we're gonna change the world man
you know and and we always fail we tried
we were surprised we linger through
Feeny while I was you know wherever
optimists you know and so I think that
that's the hypothesis I mean that's the
big hypothesis there's a bunch of small
ones right around kind of what role does
paper to play in this process and and
some emerge through the work you know
when we found how exciting the data
entry was we could that's created a new
set of hypotheses around whether that's
a valuable learning experience
hypothesis is the one that I kind of
ended with and you know one example of
that and just being engaged in also the
summer project where you saw those youth
present at the end with the air quality
I was over there on the first day you
know this is Sarah's work she was there
continuously throughout and again I
should also say it's the Lawrence Hall
of Science and the eBay's program
provided a lot of that support in
scaffolding so I was there on the first
day kids were totally not into it and
they were just like hanging out you know
they were like a couple of them just
left you know they just left and and
they everyone was just like you know
just like whatever man and then you saw
you know where they got to it now I have
only seen these videos I wasn't even
present in that room but I was like
shocked
because I'd seen those people in the
first day and then they were not into it
man they were not you know they were not
participating in by the end they were
and that guy that you saw at the end the
saying you got to know there's a problem
when there is a problem he wasn't even
in the class he just halfway through the
semester just walking off the street you
know West Oakland right he's just there
it's in the church you know where this
is all going on he just walked in this
sounds fun you know and he's into it you
know he's doing it and you know back
answer he gave was actually in response
to a community member so that was a
public meeting though they were
presenting the results community members
were there and one woman raises her hand
and says this is crazy man two people
does happening what are you gonna do
about this you know what's gonna happen
about this and first let's do it for
like we're just kids you know we don't
know we're gonna do but then he gave
that answer which I thought was a great
one you know and answered her a question
you